okay
let's start now
thanks for for coming and coming time
my name is Roger artero I'm Microsoft
cloud developer Advocate on the cloud
native in containing space
what that means means that I'm the guy
that globally talked with the community
bring back the feedback for the team
we developing new feature to bring back
for you all that cycle
I'm not selling anything here I'm just
showing the new technology service
container apps
but today is not about Microsoft only
it's about containers
okay containers4.net Developers
and I have been working with continuous
it's like 2014 15.
then it was nice to see that transition
from from Docker to kubernetes
going for the public clouds and
and become you know mainstream for many
companies
I think was a journey in the beginning
many people said I don't care about
containers maybe two or three years to
try again
and we'll never use containers before
who never did like a Docker Brown before
never did never ever
did a dock around okay it's good I'm
going to do one for you today
just remember if I under my last talk
there's a commit that I create two years
ago
to publish content videos blogs
if you have any content that you want to
publish
and even if you never spoke before even
if you've never presented me another
language before I'm happy to record in
your language there are two languages
there Portuguese in English more English
but because I speak both languages
I'm also doing both in both language but
you are welcome to my other languages as
well
and please subscribe
and best to join
and if you want to be part of the
community you want to help if you want
to become a mentor to help other people
to create content as well
that's what we do
we break the ice we help people to
to be part of the community and just say
give me a detail
maybe it can help some way okay
the first thing a little bit different
from what we talked at the first session
today
um we're going to talk about local
development
anyone using those things there are few
projects there that you can use for
local containers development
Dr desktop who's using Docker desktop
majority
Venture desktop and one using Ranger
but branch of desktop
no one okay
I'm using Russia desktop here there will
be nice to show and if you never use
that
um and you're using kind
to create a cluster to create a
kubernetes cluster nobody
nice
k3d with Docker anyone
k3d is one
those are different ways to create okay
you can get canonical micro Cades
where you can quickly create a class
even create like a mode node cluster as
well you can even use micro case in
production
for iot environments for you know small
environments you can probably a better
distribution to use that and k3s is part
now of cncf the cloud native computer
Foundation
as official you know kubernetes
distribution
it's very lightweight
they get all those you know kubernetes
components and they put in a single
binary
and you can have like a cluster with you
know I think less than if I'm not going
500 megabytes or something like you can
have a class of running and that's very
nice for developing in Russia desktop is
using k3s
because skateways was originally done by
venture
um Rachel now is part of Susan the Linux
distribution and
and now they decide to create Russia
desktop see those are the options that
we have
and one thing I was showing before is
the first thing for the developer to
understand about containers is how to
pack your package for your application
How I build my application there is no
MSI to install
um
we who is the time from MSI times and I
always have to pack your application
desktop forever yeah it's not even on
visual studio anymore you have this
extension now I have to install MSI to
create like a a package
Docker file is your package keep in mind
that if you don't have an image you
don't have applications to deploy you
need a container image
a lot of people say it's a Docker image
it's a Docker image
but now is our oci open container
initiative that
you know many companies are part of this
this part of census where you create
this format
that's compatible is open
but we still call it okay containers
Docker image
okay
um
and the first thing you do like for DOT
net for example you create a base image
voice like from
you create one image
okay when you run a command like Docker
build
to build to pack your application
that's what they do they go for this
Docker file they run the first prong
create one base image
then in.net normally we create another
one like a second step
where
we
we go build
then to build the application to do like
a.net build you need like SDK that is
starting from sdk6
you copy a project
you run.net restore you copy your source
you build the application
and that's it
and all these blue you know layers
that's what you call Docker image
if you go and talk and do Docker inspect
and that image
you're going to see all those layers
those are file systems
with all the files change on each
operation that we did on the docker file
and the next step now is create another
phone to publish
and then you run.net publish
now we have you know your application
building and published
and you create another step called final
coming out from the base image because
we don't need the SDK
please don't deploy in production you
know from the SDK image because it's
very heavy
though this base image there on the top
that we use as base that's very
lightweight
okay just a few megabytes SDK is is a
huge one
well it's going to happen after I go and
I crop my code
the other the other image can be deleted
it's just like a temporary file that
Docker is creating to build you know the
docker build processes create to create
the image after that's done
we have the command the entry point by
going to call.net in your application
and that's the final image everything
disappear
everything was just like
doing the process of creating the image
but the final result is the final image
with only like a lightweight base image
in your application top
nothing more
and that's what goes production
and that's we have to learn how to build
that
when let me stop here
and show a few things on my local
environment
the first one
I'm using Linux I'm on Windows
but it's all Double SL Windows was using
Windows subsystem for Linux here
if you're not
give a go
because you know everything that you're
doing developing these days will be
Linux
we're going to see Azure container apps
a new application here there is no
windows containers there it's just Linux
containers
okay we don't have
you know estimated to see when
discontinence is coming you'll be Linux
containers
.net6now.net7 I mean you can just
migrate your application you can run now
on Linux as your server
um the legacy is there there are a few
options to deploy you know food.net
framework but for net core
before pretty much all the other
language you'll be on Linux and
if you never use Docker like I said he
said never use Dock and that's the doc
dock a common line
if I do docker
you can see all the things that you can
do with the command line
and a simple one is Docker run
I want to get it got like a shell
interactive shell and let's do like a
nginx
and let's put it like pots
89 going to Port 80.
see what I'm doing here I'm running a
container
docker
okay
um I'm asking to map both 89 on my
machine to put 80 on the container and
I'm using nginx like a base nginx image
there you go and your next running
what I do go to the browser
localhost
if you need a little Docker run now you
know how to do a docker
using sodak desktop or ratio in five
minutes you can or maybe 10 depends how
long it takes to install but and you
have this
then how many I can do it
because I put interactive but let's hope
another one
um
local one you can run detection and you
can see
nginx
um
what is that 87 Maybe
oh
I'm going to spot the earring
there's your next
oh I put a lot of Commander
look around the
SP
nginx
there you go I create one if I do docker
BS
I have my command my my container
running there on top nginx engine X
and now we can go parties
I think I think I stop it because
um
let's see if it's still running
yeah I think the part number Maybe music
for something else
I have learned a few things but just
which one
this public conflict on the
on the report by the way you got the
idea you can do that as many as you want
how people do it
anyone want to say here with the
developer is using talking How We Do It
is one thing called Docker compose
that you can come you know Define how
you want our application have the front
end will be a web application like that
then you have like a database maybe like
maybe a SQL Server running locally
and there is a lot of say another thing
say Docker Docker compose up they got
that definition
and they do the docker ground for us
that's what they call Docker compose
simple like that
but you can also Define a network
and they say okay those two containers
they're going to talk with each other
inside like a aveenet
it's like a composer very nice to do
that and there are a lot of people using
that you're going to find if I developer
if you moved on your job you're going to
find a lot of Docker compose around you
know the code
it's like a make file you have a
definition there how to create the
things a lot of people do with makefire
yeah just do like a make and have like
talk around that there's nothing wrong
with that just I'm giving options here
for you to understand how are you going
to find those things in your job you
know you know in the next next project
that you get you have to understand that
because without that it's not going
anywhere
and um
that's the that's the docker one okay
and the same thing for the image Docker
image you can get the image that you can
download like a pool you can get the
image
um but that's like old school
okay nobody's using dock anymore it's
just for development just for local
development yes keep using that
but in production now
we're using kubernetes
then we can get the same image
that you can do like a Docker build here
and if I go for my
if I go back and stop that
I'm side
a project here see these are not that
project
I can
I can do something like that
I can use local build build X
and I can do something like that
yes get the right one
yep let's see
test
you give a name for that
and that dot at the end
ask them to look for the docker file
inside that folder the folder that you
are in this case you can see there is a
Docker file there yep here on top
then when I click there it's going to
build the image
and that's the docker build
you see the slide that I went for all
the layers all the Thrones
and all the layers when you do the
docker build that's exactly what
happened you're going to knock a file
you're going to do exactly what we did
manually there on this slide
and you can learn and see what they do
from you know from the logs but
and there is a docking spec that you can
do and loop the image as well that's
very nice for debugging for you know
when someone asks you what's on that
image you can see how many layers you
have you can try to compress the layers
um
but one last thing here is
Docker kind of caches the image that's
why it doesn't take the same time when
you build the second time
the first time I built that took longer
I had to download the base image from
like a hedge tree
it's like a with a JavaScript developer
like a package any package management
that you use for JavaScript you have to
download no get package
you have to download this base image
from somewhere it's a repo there we
download that image and we use that to
build our application
and that's take time but once you have
these in Cache
that's fast because there are a lot of
caching on those layers
and it's not very common for Windows
people to understand that because in
Linux everything is a file
in Windows it wasn't like that like
from Windows 2016 server they change a
lot to make
you know Windows be like similar to
Linux on that aspect and they had to
include like registry they had to
include all the files and now you can do
a Docker build also you create like a a
container for Windows containers as well
I'm not going I I talk a little bit
about Windows containers on the previous
session but not on that one and
and that's Docker in a nutshell the only
thing we have to really use from Docker
now
locally if you want to play with
something
and a nice way to show that is
code space let me restart my code space
anyone using Code space GitHub code
space
is a container it's nothing more than a
container
and if you don't know Visual Studio code
now can
run inside the container
okay visual can run inside your windows
it can run inside window subsystem for
Linux that's Linux
and can also run in a remote machine
and you can also run inside the
container
then you have to install that extension
show here
remote Explorer
and you see the targets on the top code
space containers
SSH targets as like a remote machine
nwsl Windows successfully looks
every time that you find like any report
that shows
something like that Dev container
see that for DOT Dev container that
means
that is a container that like visual
code is running in a container
if you you can use that same depth
folder there
to open this whole repository on Visual
Studio code in your machine create a
container
from that definition
and if you go inside that Dev one you're
going to see there's a locker file there
and that tokafa is my environment in my
develop environment now now I can use
Docker yet there is still using dock a
lot
gold space is using Docker everywhere
that means that you can now
right now what do you want in your
developing environment
and that's what nice thing
in cool space but you can do that in
your machine
if you create a Dev container there are
documentation you can go there
you can Define what you want you know
all the libraries the language that
you're using all the SLI
they're going to create these container
image that's your developed environment
now we're going to work inside that
container
then when you open Visual Studio code
they're not running your machine anymore
looks like that's funny in my machine
but it's not look I hit the button cold
space
look the other the other one Double SL
IDE 2204
maybe too small but at the body in green
that's where they're running
when you open
because our web application they're
going to install all your environment
including excitations you can Define on
that Dev content extensions everything
that you want
using that base image with audio tools
that you know you prepare there and you
have your environment
and we have been you know adding that
containers in
a lot of Microsoft repos open source
projects
and just pay attention now when you see
a ripple and that's going you're going
to find that there are a lot of that
container folded there
but there's one another thing here
is one extension called docker
the same thing I was doing on command
line there Dr PS Docker you can do here
from the command line
I can see the the image let's scroll
this down I can see the docker image
Alpine engine X dabbing
even my API in his email open API
and I can see everything that's running
those are containers running on my
machine
can I do more yes you can you can now go
and see occupant classes from here
then I have something called
that's the iaks cluster running on azure
that's the first one
and I go workloads deployment
uh it's probably not connected
let's see this one
and I have that's why my local one said
current cluster
nodes
there's my Ranger desktop
hang on
yeah
let's refresh here then I don't know
what happened on my musical code but
I mean the extension sometimes can crash
let's see if my class is running how can
I check if my my class is running
I use the kubernetes command line
do get all
Dash capital A means that I go to get
all everything that's running on all
kubernetes namespace
yeah it's running
it is running
and that's my
yep that's my Russia desktop class
and that's exactly this cluster here
when you install ratio desktop you have
this environment here
you can connect with your windows
subsystem for Linux
means that they're going to give us you
know they keep CTL the docker cell are
going to give
everything for eyes we don't have to
install yourself
you can create a cluster not just docker
it has two options you can use Docker
Docker D that's open source by the way
we call Docker D Mobi project
or you can use container d
many people asking that kubernetes not
using Docker D anymore yeah that's true
they're only using containerd
and if you want to go you know forget
about dog hacking use container D only
and there is another common line called
Ned CTL that he plays the docker salad
then you don't even have Docker comment
anymore you'll be net CTL run and you
run the container
okay
and probably that's what's going to
happen
but what happened here I can I can
create any combined cluster to work you
know on my local machine
or inside code space as well because
you're using tanks remember the other
ones called kinds
I can create my class inside code space
see I'm give you options here is Russia
desktop he's running on my windows
and I have a class of running
but I also have a glass of running
inside my code space that's my machine
I have a repo with gold space there's
only Cloud on GitHub
and I also have I think I have gone here
get clusters
yep I have one class there if I go on
the extension
there you go this one's working
if I
if I go for this whole Space
you can see call the NS running there
that's cool space not on machine it's on
GitHub
I have a guy I have Docker here and if
the docker PS you have kind running
what kind does they create one whole
cluster inside the docker container
they create this container and now they
create a class inside that
and you can create as many as you want
you can create classes with different
versions you can create a cluster just
for pipeline to do like a test
you can run your whole text and destroy
the whole thing
and there are a lot of people doing that
because lightweight they're going to
create run the test do like our
integration tests if they want and
destroy the whole thing
um
that's on on code space
and this one
is on my local environment
and I single that I like on on Russia
desktop is they can do ports forward for
us
because
Russia that stop you on Windows they run
inside windows subsystem for Linux see
one thing inside another
then we have to do the pause forwarding
four windows
for your application that's running
inside there then
they made that easier for us we've port
forwarding here
and they also included you know cocaine
image scanning
because her name is Kenny is
you built you did like Docker build five
months ago
but it has to keep updating it's like a
update your Linux yourself
there's no patching with containers
anymore but you do you rebuild the image
and you publish again
is a bootable that's what cncf cloud
database you will rebuild and you
publish again
then uh on Azure on AKs
there is a ways for to automate this
process
there's actually Defender now that can
be doing like Lobby scanning on your
applications running on AKs
and once it detects something they are
less they even can trigger Pipeline and
it can be building redeploy the
application
everything can be automated
okay and um as a Defender is available
for for AKs
and you can you can use like Azure
policies on a case
to also
say what Docker image can be deployed in
your environment you want to avoid that
someone go there and deploy our old
image you can just allow a specific
image or image is coming from like your
private like repository not like from a
public place
then you make sure that nobody is going
to publish anything in your cluster
that's not safe that's not coming from
like a source of Truth
and not coming from your Pipelines
not coming from all these scanning
process that you are having place I
think that's that's a big one
that's the the Russia but Russia desktop
has one thing called
um
dashboard
if you don't know how to open because
many people don't know you right click
here and click dashboard
on the clock
and that's pretty much like an extension
that we have on vs code you can see the
whole workloads cluster everything
you can see pretty much the whole
cluster let's say deployments
is pretty nice
you can even create a deployment from
here look at this
Okay so
why should I stop I think is a very nice
option and for local development
and you can have all as well can use a
visual code extension
the docker as well the docker compose
I think you're going at some point it
was all of them
and give you more a little bit more
options
um
what more
from here
go back for my slide a little bit
any question on that before I go for
Azure content apps
makes sense that like help a little bit
if you never use containers question
the publish
and that's that's a different place to
do it you know um
because they published there just like a
copy
at the end of the day we're just copying
and maybe we could do Docker publish
inside the same one and do yep that's
fine
I don't see a reason I think it was just
big it would be clear it would be okay
make sure that on that step the only
thing you have there is a Polish
and make sure that nobody is going to
copy anything else
I think it's more to avoid that
because imagine if there are a lot of
things that someone can just start
copying things
once you do the only thing you'll be on
that you know public should be the
publish
there is nothing more like gold or
anything then I think that's the the
main reason
make sure that you you know like the
fighter was not even to looking not
looking to the SDK one that's building
the application
let me make sure that nobody's touching
more than you should and the only thing
you run there is a the publishing
command
um yeah I don't see many reasons but
probably probably
so easy what
the advantage of using containers nice
one
the first one is
olate your dependencies
okay you
like when I have a VM you have a lot of
stuff there that you don't need it
um yeah you can you can using things
like ash cupbeca to build images only
you know minimal and input application
but the containers one thing is that
dependency you can just put what you
need it
another thing is
container they share the same you know
Linux candle
they are like a uh operate system
isolation
different from hyper-v or another like a
VM that's more like hypervisor isolation
and that's been lightweight that boots
liking less than a second there are some
containers but like in microseconds
and that millisecond microsecond you
know boot like to start a container all
that Docker image caching everything
makes the thing be faster to boot
there's a lot of techniques in keep
improving keep improving
um
I think for me that's the main advantage
like many years ago like in.net
framework you could not install.net
framework in the same computer like you
have to upgrade the fashion you cannot
have two versions of this same machine
not that guy can but
yeah and um
that brings like security problems a lot
of other things
only that for me I think um
makes sense and the way that you escaped
because lightweight
you can just you know boot very quick
you can skip up and down up and down all
the time
and you don't do patching if anything
change you just rebuild the image and
hit deploy
because fast because it can
and I think you know that's what many
people like in containers is that
and then come kubernet says uh okay
straight to that okay now that we have
these containers
and by the way it containers are there
for a long time since like you know
Solaris and
they just keep improving people can
start creating libraries libraries
libraries and then Docker came and
create like a even easier library to be
used
and then become popular
but I know company like Telstra that you
saw Arizona how many years ago maybe
20. maybe more than 15 years ago and
then
those isolation by Keanu is something
that's there for a long time I mean
became popular now it makes sense
otherwise it wasn't be used by all the
you know Cloud providers
in some point what's going to happen
you're going to use containers you don't
even know
um for example Azure container apps
you're going to deploy application now
they're going to see exactly Azure codes
and apps Next Step
then you're going to understand what I'm
saying
let me go this one
I think
yeah let's go collapse
now that was like five six years ago you
know containers was the beginning now
they are everywhere and now we are
building things on top of containers or
top of container orchestrators on top of
kubernetes and that's another content
apps
we try to simplify but still there
kubernetes there okay the depth Envoy
the all cncf projects
we have these serverless
um
what you call
serverless container for microservice
for modern applications on top of
kubernetes and these are the projects
and
what you can have with that you can use
any language because you pack inside the
container you see isolation
it could be running now five any
language that you want on the same host
complete isolated dependencies
how do that on the end a new phone
number.net and Java on the VM in Python
and go
you know like I don't know like any
dependence that you have for those
applications have to install everything
together in a container now they could
be all running on the same physical
machine but completely isolated
and only each one only can see your
dependence completely isolated and
that's the nice thing of spontaneous
apps and kubernetes as well
any language
um for production for microservice using
something called depa who watched the
Dapper session that we had here before
in one watch he had one yeah we had a
session on that Dapper is nothing more
than
dotnet Enterprise Library
if anyone is old enough use.net
Enterprise Library he is there not who
is that dot NetApp plus Library what was
that
caching identity yeah authentication
things like that
was like a library that could do a lot
of things
and and it wasn't on.net yet
then people start to create those these
library that you can use and there is a
lot of became has like a
a guideline and became a library of
something you know people thought let's
create like
was more like a guidance
library that became very popular and
became like something and that place is
like that what we need to develop Cloud
native applications we need
um we need that communication TLS
communication between the microservice
we need someone to manage a certificate
that communication we need
we need to talk with like a pub sub like
rescash we need to talk with Cosmo DB
everything that you can remove from your
application code and create this library
that can and do a lot of things
if he's good or not he's up to you to
decide
but you can use it even using the
aperture scope in the library and using
that
but what they're trying to do you don't
have to install these 100 sdks to talk
with all these other products
you have one single Library that's
called Depot
but the way that we deploy that you know
is a cloud native way
and in kubernetes we we deployed that by
the sidecar container
a sidecar container is
is my personal assistant here okay I
have my application running inside the
container
and when Docker creates a container they
create like a namespace
that's exactly what isolate the
container from the oldest container
create like a namespace increase the C
group in the namespace and then you are
isolated here
then inside that same name space they
create another car another container
another process a container is a process
for Depot
and we talk with that by grpc that's
very fast
kind of they're not running together
it's a separate process but it's a fast
communication and I say that I want to
talk with that microservice I want to
talk with that microservice
then dapa is going to inject the
uh I don't know where you are I know
that I want to talk to you
okay you are the micro Services I want
to call I ask them they know where you
are service Discovery that's one thing
depa does service discovery
then you can integrate with server
switch cover even outside your cluster
there are companies using service you
know third-part service Discovery
products
and then
just do that I want to save this Pub sub
on Red's cash
who's using rights cache that's very
popular rights for caching for session
for anything you can do that with that
but just say I want to send that
but you could do that in development
then imagine when you deploy from one
customer that customers say hang on we
don't use Reds cashier sorry
your applications are going to be used
by our company because we don't have red
cache
but that only
you know can talk with Red's cash in
many other Pub sub
missions
then you don't have to change anything
in your application
your application will be going to be
able to talk with these other products
that are compatible with that I think
that's what dapa does is a library and I
I recommend you to have a look and give
feedback because there's a lot of to be
improved there but
and I'm saying that just for you to see
how the the container apps is growing
then it was built on kubernetes
depth and another another one called
Cada
Keda is how are you going to scale those
applications now
High scale application on kubernetes
how many requests you have received
if your CPU is like nine percent if your
memory is along the top using all the
memory how are you going to create
another instance
horizontal scaling how are you going to
do that then
this project was born at Microsoft
exactly to you know fill this Gap and
now it's used by everyone
um on the community was donated to
census
and now you can scale for things like
message queue there is a hundred
messages on the Queue you can scale your
application based on how many message
you have on the queue and I have
application here to process that message
queue
every time that there is a 100 message I
create a new a new instance there are
500 message I create five instances and
I keep scaling up and down kubernetes
containers very fast scaling up and down
milliseconds process Bank sometimes runs
for seconds
sometimes just for microseconds yeah
milliseconds depends of your application
and yep it's not doing anything scale
down
because you know it can but if
application takes one minute to scale up
you know to be ready like a Java or Java
application then that's the reason some
people start using.net core
you know the latest fashion that's very
lightweight where you know boot very
fast go laying rust because they can be
faster than you know but Java now is
coming back as well it's very fast to
put you know the latest travel version
oh I had problems like you have a age
and uh like age was
yeah it was very low I think like a
minute to boot like a container but not
anymore see all the lingers are getting
ready for containers now they're all
pretty much ready
and there is no excuse like
um Azure has a service called Azure
spring boot or spring clouds there's a
partnership with VMware
and we deliver like a hope
a spring Cloud environment that runs on
top of you know kubernetes as well
and you can deploy up applications if
you have Java applications Azure spring
cloud is like Azure content apps for
Java you know it's like it's a platform
using VMware technology deliver on azure
and but the main thing I was saying for
him was a application possibility
hosting
um
you know that catered up anyway evil if
you don't always the lightweight you
know reverse proxy and then
um there's all everyone is using Army
proxy on the cloud native because you
can
and be using that all the Ingress
controllers or the all the traffic go
through the invoice
as well
and what was delivered a mass built at
Ms build
we release
um
all these main features for Azure
container apps and GA by the way you can
use in production now
and I I think it was the first product
where I really delivered pretty much all
the Enterprise features from the
beginning from the G8 date
because look there why do you have the
v-net manage identity log special
domains
all the probes
visual integration we have
that's just what was released at the
build but the other things are already
there volumes as well in preview you can
attach files
means that pretty much everything that
you do in app service today you can move
application here
I don't recommend you to start with
kubernetes with Azure kubernetes service
I recommend you start with Azure
container apps
and if you need something more advanced
like service mesh Azure policy or
something about a different network
topology
um
you maybe need a recommended service but
what you have there
you have the same thing that have Azure
service is authentication it can have
ease Authentication
means that you know
open ID connectors there that's
available you can move the same way here
and that authentication kind of hides
um you know identity and um
has all the you know the authentication
authorization for your application on
that layer outside the application that
means that you're not going to write a
lot of code if you if you don't want you
know you can manage your own on that
configuration level here
that takes a while to do you know
authentication right in my opinion
because if you never have done and most
of the developers they start application
without anything there's not educational
we just prototyping there is not
education there is no authorization
there is no certificate there is nothing
how about starting with that from day
one
you know and
he came now they manage Secrets they
managing grass controllers Ingress is
all the traffic coming means that there
is like a routing within web proxy that
um it's all https out of the box
continuous deployment
you can do kind of a githubs you can you
can configure like a git repo repository
every time that every time that
something changed there
they're going to get your Docker file
they're going to rebuild
the image using as a container has
actually builds if you don't know Azure
content hash there is a build option
there they're going to build that inside
Azure container history
keep the new version there I'm going to
hit deploy application
you don't have to have anything
okay
um
they're going to configure GitHub as
well
another way you can bring your domain
you can bring your certificate
in depa and Keda they are out of the box
there means that we can we can just
Define what you want to use from the
Apple I'm going to show later manage
identity service connect with a new
thing on Azure that allows you to
connect your application with all the
Azure settings like a SQL database a
cosmo DB
Sim preview
but I think that's going to be across
Azure not like Azure container apps
means that you're going to simplify that
communication between
and
um
and those other servers like database
and it was released I think two days ago
or something
um as I started gaps they started gaps
now you can
um
you can pass the Authentication
for your microservice to run your own
Azure content apps
and you can integrate that
authentication there even authorization
if the the Scopes there's a easy way to
do that means that you could run your
front end if it's just like a web
application ship away and run audio
back-end apis microservice on Azure
content apps and they can talk with each
other nicely it's another way
another thing people use is uh revision
is very similar to slots on app service
means that there are two ways here one
is single Vision every time that I
deploy I override the previous one
another one is multiple revisions
what that means I always deployed your
version
I keep both running
and then I can split the traffic if I
want if I if I want to send you know 20
of the traffic to the new version just
to see how that goes
and keep the V1 running there
you can do that you can split the
traffic until you move all the traffic
to the new version then you can safely
remove the old version
um that's very nice I think F7 second
you only swap
but here you can you can split the
traffic
scaly you can use anything that kada can
do that's a lot I'm going to show on the
next slide and
and all the monitoring logs you can even
connect inside the container to see
what's happening inside the container
um apps
and it's all going to log analytics as
well and you can even console you can
log in and do like a do whatever you
want inside if you want
and those are the applications that
we're talking a lot you know um
for Azure container apps is microservice
using that like I was talking
simplify communication simplify
anything that you want I have some
slides if we have time I can show a
little bit more
revisions
means that it can deploy V1 V2 V3 and
keeping
you can do like a canary deployment
where you're going to send like a small
percentage of a traffic blue green
deployment that's the only way that you
really can
guarantee that your application be you
know
no timeout to be 100 you know percent
available all the time is it he's doing
like that that's exactly how kubernetes
works
uh web application there are many
options for that but if you need a web
application where you can scale to zero
and don't pay anything
that's the only one don't tell anyone
that I said that but
Azure container apps is the only
application that scales to zero
and you don't pay anything hey Cassie
can do that yes you can
but
Azure container apps the only one that
you can keep one nieces running
and your page is like a small standby
fee
then you can look at the price for
agriculture apps
and there's a standby fee what that
means if there is no HTTP request coming
from your application
like the whole night
you only pay that standby fee you don't
pay the full price
just because you want to keep one nieces
running but you can scale down to zero
like Azure functions for example yeah
you can if you just like process like a
message queue
when I finish processing I scale to zero
don't pay anything I have a field
deployed here that I'm not pay anything
because it's all
nobody's calling and there is no cost
scaled down to zero and if a website
that can you know start up be liking in
like in three seconds
um you can even because they're going to
keep it right
if your application comes back very
quick in milliseconds
they can scale to burn and works
like that
that's why it's smaller better because
it boots faster
another one is background processing and
vetting process as well
that's what talk about message queue
um event bars anything that you wanna
talk
um
I'm not going to skip this one but like
that you can create a Content
environment
and you can Define another thing that's
very important Zone redundance
in Sydney we have in Australia you know
East we have Zone riddance
and that's out of the box on magical
labs
it means that if there is one zone
inside you know Australia is failing
they still be another region brand new
application
and that's on day one that you define
monitoring log analytics like I said in
networking
and you can do internal and external
could be completely private Network
and that's what they call environment
and have the inside that environment
like a app service environment
let's compare but we have that
environment where you deploy your
applications they all inside the same
network they can talk with each other
um and that's how that works
in our revision there's like a
deployment on container apps
is a pod and a poding kubernetes like I
said they can have multiple processes
inside that isolation lab
and you can run side cars you can run
um you know anything that you want to
run inside that pod
and you can have multiple revisions
inside the same container app
container revisions the GitHub actions
that I was talking about
container registry
and GitHub actions they create that for
us
secret management
logging
and that's just like a demo here but
I'm gonna go from one slide here at the
front we probably the best to show
yeah because we talk about the depth
that's what the Dapper is for
the options that we have on happen Pub
sub
uh secret Management Service invocation
State Management
and something like that you can
you can have these sidecar container
they're called depa there on this side
and you can you can make this personal
assistant to do all the job for you and
to find out where
um the other services that service
Discovery deck observability they can
talk with zipking Jager Epping sites
you don't have to write these codes you
just configure that when they are going
to send all everything for any of those
products and probably more in the future
because there are a lot of people doing
integration with Lepa
then we don't care about this code
anymore that's nice you know they use
open telemetry
and Pub sub like he says the borrow
Kafka service bus
um uh was that rabbitamikum
Google Cloud Pub sub as well Amazon SMS
um
they messaged you there
he said you don't write this code you
just say my personal assistant he know
how to do it I just asked him he can do
it best step that's a library
um
secret management anyone using hashcope
vault I'm pretty sure there are people
using vote yeah
and then Azure key Vote or vote
I think all the big Enterprise they use
vote then you go there with your
application with your knowledge and
they're going to ask you to integrate
your phone
if application is already doing that
simplifies
doesn't mean that you have to use the
app to use Azure content apps no not at
all you can just disable and not use
them okay it's just like an option that
we're giving there for free and
installing but you can manage everything
yourself there's you know there's no
requirement for that
um
yeah but you can you can use
there before these things
and like I said the cloud data from
Azure is openshift
Azure commanded service container apps
functions
spring cloud
and there's one thing that is all here
is the new hybrid is called Azure Arc
where we can now have a single you know
pane of glass where you can manage
clusters running everywhere
and there is one a gas called Azure
Azure command service
hey CI this form premise
now we can get AKs and you can deploy on
Windows server on premise if you have to
Anna my application cannot be public
cloud has to be running
on premise
no problem you can use AKs as well uh
and you can use Azure Arc to manage
or another Cloud on premise from this
from the same place including applied
policies
um from you know a single plane that's
what they call
and see
I think we don't have much time but
questions
we we can have questions
foreign
to be
completely stateless you don't want to
keep any state inside the application
anymore
like with VMS you know save files
and that might help with that because it
can get these out of your application
and you can use blob storage Azure blob
storage it can use red cache you can use
any Pub sub
um you know messaging system message
queue to get all this information
outside your application application
should be just running there completely
you know there's no estate there they
can
it's just processing the request once
they finish processing that they can
just shut down
um yeah and that's not about container
that's like uh you should be doing that
for any development that you're doing in
VMS don't save anything on the disk
um when I say that we have volumes like
Azure files they're not inside the
container they're outside
we can map Azure files multiple times in
multiple different containers instance
the same folder we can map we can mount
then if the container dies we just Mount
again on the next one
when we release the next fashion
but the container should be completely
you know um
illustrate there no fires anything
it can have like temporary files you
know do processing
but nothing that you cannot lose
um
oh you attached like a volume
that could be outside
and that's why kubernetes has all these
volumes and now on Azure content apps we
have
yeah you can you can have like a femoral
disc or it can have like a
zure file somewhere then yeah if you do
that you're safe you can do the same for
Azure container instance
um now you can do that for web service
that's a nice thing because app service
was kind of causing this problem because
they have a big disk there
and we're just checking things there
now they they did like integration with
I think there's a files and you can save
that outside
and
yeah that's why normally we people don't
do much things for production like
database where you need a lot of storage
in containers we do but
we have a way to manage you know to to
shot all the the load of the storage
and for you to do that yourself I don't
recommend just get like Cosmic B SQL or
any MySQL
uh fully managed by the cloud and use
that
because storage pretty hard you know
like volumes have to extend the volume
because you never know if it's going to
grow fast or not it can get a lot of
load suddenly and
I think database always open to be
outside
and you talk to them and that service
connector will be easier to talk like as
a result of Education
and um
yeah you can you can do like a lot of
people run all these things on
containers but you have to make sure
that is one thing called
um
stateful sets but that's more for AKs
um where you can yeah when I guess
probably be the best solution if I run
something like that not all 14 apps
unless you are happy with Azure fires or
you know in attaching Azure files the
performance should be good enough for
what you say if it fires it's fine but
for database you probably need a better
performance you know and then
those blob storage things are not going
to be probably the best performance for
database then
you need like Azure disk or something
and on a case you can attach a disk on
your container
that's the difference
and that's why for this kind of database
or anything that needs a lot of storage
yeah goofway gas
um
and now we have this the coursesi driver
where you can have Azure disks and even
extend these can
snapshot disk you can do a lot of things
now that wasn't available before it's
got a favor because we're doing that for
ourselves you know and then the
customers are going to use
I think we are over time already if you
want to leave and question that nope
thank you thank you everyone appreciate
it
[Applause]